Coffee tables are no longer just slabs of wood made for feet to rest upon.
Instead, many furniture designers are choosing to incorporate art...
...into the once standard living room staple.
A French interior designer has created a coffee table which performs double duty...
...as it also serves as a birdcage.
While the table itself is somewhat traditional, constructed of solid wood and standing on four legs,...
...three clear vessels emerge from the furniture piece's tabletop.
Underneath that same surface is additional space comprised of see-through glass...
...which encompasses about half the length of the coffee table.
These areas are solely for the birds.
Fake tree branches which are made from steel can be seen inside of the glass,...
...giving the birds a place to perch.
The branches are coated with polyester putty, giving it a real-life look...
...and softening the constructed material for the birds' comfort.
The designer stated, "The idea was to develop a cage that would break conventional codes."
"The bird is staged as in a theater."
What do you think?
Do you like the table?